This morning, Ukrainians
told to take shelter
as Russia
launched yet another major
aerial assault on Ukraine.
Ukrainian officials say
Russia fired some 55 missiles al
the country overnight aimed
specifically at energy facilitie
And while nearly two
dozen of those missiles were shu
Many did hit their targets.
One man killed by falling
missile fragments.
This latest
round of attacks
comes not coincidentally just ho
after the U.S.
and several
European allies vowed to send ta
to Ukraine, something
President Zelensky
has been asking for for months.
Joining me now
to discuss, former CIA director
and former U.S.
CENTCOM commander,
General David Petraeus.
General,
thanks so much for joining this
Good to be with you.
So you're aware of the debate
leading up to this.
There appears to be unity
now among Western allies.
Are tanks
the weapon that
Ukrainian forces need now?
Absolutely.
Ideally, we would have made this
even a bit earlier
so that they can train fully on
and integrate them into their fo
But without tanks,
you don't have the centerpiece
of the kind of combined arms ope
that will be necessary
to enable
Ukraine
to have successful counter
offensive operations
this spring and summer
to liberate more of their territ
from Russian occupation.
It's interesting
that in the Kremlin,
they downplayed the issue of tan
just saying, well,
this might leave things a little
but of course, it's the punitive
it's the punishment
that they're meting out
with these 55 missiles
that they shot at Ukraine last n
Again, targeting, of course,
civilian infrastructure, not mil
Again, a violation of the
laws of land warfare.
But at the end of the day,
this is a very significant devel
Clearly, the United States
ultimately recognizes
it's necessary for them
to give a certain number
of our M-1 Abrams
tanks to get Germany to agree
to send their weapons,
and also to allow Poland
and other countries
to send their tanks to Ukraine a
But this is a major development.
It will enable the offensives
that are necessary
for Ukraine
and without which they just
couldn't have conducted.
As you're aware,
one factor
in all of these weapons decision
going back
to the very start of the war, ha
not just
is this the right weapon for Ukr
but also could this go too far?
So as to provoke Russia
into some sort of retaliation or
the conflict into one between
the West and Russia?
Do you have any concern about ta
raising that risk too far?
Not really.
No, I don't
think that this is going
to trigger something.
And I think
actually we have done now
with the countries,
the US, the Western countries
have done quite a good job
of conveying to Russia
that if they were to use,
for example,
tactical nuclear weapons
or attack a NATO's country,
Russia would end up in a worse s
Than it was before it was that o
And so I think that deterrence i
here.
I don't think this is the issue
that would result in some
escalation that should be of eno
concern to us.
Although again,
all they could do
is just launch what we hope
is a dwindling number
of their missiles at Ukraine las
This war has taken on
many characteristics
of a war of attrition,
just just horrendous military ca
on those battlefields in the yea
without much forward
or backwards
progress, as well
as, as you referenced, tremendou
civilian casualties
as Russia tries to reign down,
you know, punishment in effect o
Do you see anything
changing that dynamic
in the coming months?
Yes.
What I hope
is that we will continue
to do
everything that we can to enable
to convince Vladimir Putin
that this war is unsustainable,
keeping in mind
that Russia has already
lost at least eight times the so
in 11 months
that they lost
and nearly ten years of war
in Afghanistan
of course,
which was unsustainable for the
And also that as we tighten furt
the economic, financial
and personal sanctions
and export
controls on Russia
that we can convince Putin
that this war is unsustainable
on the home front as well.
That's got to be the objective,
because until Putin recognizes
that he's not going to achieve
his ultimate goals
and that the war is not sustaina
there won't be meaningful negoti
And at that point, Ukraine,
which will need a marshal plan
for reconstruction,
will need an iron
clad security guard,
obviously needs to stop the dama
Then you could have
meaningful discussions.
And that resolution through nego
You mentioned the Afghan war, wh
looking back
historically say
was a factor
in the collapse of the Soviet Un
What is your level of concern
hope,
even if you want to describe it
But but what is the threat
to Putin's government
from the ongoing his ongoing tro
and high costs from the war in U
Yeah, no, that can't be discount
And of course,
we all think
that this is inconceivable right
You know,
you look at it,
a kleptocracy,
a dictatorship, like this and sa
there's no way that anybody
could ever mount
a coup against this and survive.
But, of course, that's right.
Before it is all of a sudden ine
And we've seen them
during the Arab Spring on decade
all the evidence
where the regime used
to be incredibly solid,
right up until it's not.
And so this has to be a concern
It's another of the elements
that should play in
as we try all together
to hasten that moment
when he recognizes
that this is an unsustainable en
He needs to negotiate some resol
and to get out of it.
Yeah.
Perhaps the reason he sits in
all those long tables
when we see him in the Kremlin.
General David Petraeus,
always good to have you on.
Thanks, Jim.
Good to be with you.